Cat Williams is a National Treasure Cat
Williams is my favorite I would have
liked it the same if he had trashed me
and during it it was so funny that it
just absolutely killed me if he's wrong
about some things I don't care it's fine
he's so entertaining and hilarious that
I I loved it and I thought Shannon sharp
did a great job do I believe Cat
Williams read 3,000 books a year between
the ages of like 4 and 12 no I do not
but I do love him so so much and love
that he would go and talk wild like
that and the fact that everyone felt
like they had to answer for it it's like
Kevin Hart is on like an NBA game or
something and they're asking him about
it like Ice Cube is like going up and
like answering to to these things I
thought that's how powerful Cat Williams
is